one day her boss used to be an old man
rocking his [ __ ] i swear
to god i can smell it
45 he's coming his deathbed
eric they brought me fisto into the mcu
he just rolls over dies and brooch falls
out
can't cap off the one division finale
without
checking out new rock stars eric
voss's breakdown of the finale i feel
like some people have been getting like
unnecessary crap on their channels about
like doing theories and easter eggs and
blaming them for
your fault i'm hyped up i blame you and
i'm like guys it's theories they're
easter eggs this is part of the fun of
engaging with
shows like this and i'll also say too
that
i especially love new rock stars because
even if there are theories that are
wrong
i feel like i still learn so much
because there's so much
research and additional context and
source material to pull from i'm still
learning a [ __ ] ton of things i think
that's why the arguments are sold so
well and why people's
theories go down that path all the time
it's tradition really enjoyed the hell
out of the finale love new rock stars
follow them today if you haven't done so
already let's get into it people let's
do it welcome back to new rockstars i'm
eric voss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode nine the series finale
a true gut punch of familial loss
overreaching fan theories
and robots talking boats let's break
down this finale scene by scene frame by
frame in some cases to point out all
those interesting details
oh my god he's gonna break down all
those things he's gonna read the whole
book they hide in these episodes has
always been my favorite part of this
i appreciate you folks for going on this
ride with me
the previously on ends with wanda from
the end of last episode yellow frames
flickering over her
the opposite you can see this is the
moment the mind stone showed her her
future as a scarlet witch
the fully powered form she becomes in
this finale episode but achieving this
status comes with
wanda having to give up her family
inside that hex
but this episode tells us that family is
never truly lost
because our souls are rooted in the
memories that we share with loved ones
so that way family can truly be forever
family is actually in the opening line
of this episode from tommy
he is my family his main priority is the
safety of his brother
say it with me vin diesel family and
after creepily rising back up
this purple blast now has a bit of bread
mixed in
showing how she stole some of wanda's
kids magic
wanda carves agatha into the house
without getting those empty boots
sticking out like the wicked witch of
the east
with this witches basketball
fireballs from rooftops red puffs of
smoke and
killing your little dog
currently directing elizabeth olsen as
she returns in doctor strange in the
multiverse
we're gonna explain how then white
vision floats down
is it really new similar to wanda's
i didn't actually realize how many
parallels there were to the wicked witch
of the east and we noticed that it said
oscar and the powerful in the background
i thought that was just like an easter
egg for the fact that sam raimi's doing
multiverse of madness but it works on so
many layers for the fact that she does
seem to have these like correlations to
wicked witch of the west
did i say easter earlier it doesn't
matter you know what trying to talk
about it's the wicked one then also to
have it with the oscar and the powerful
uh with sam raymond there like
that works on a letter that's a cool
little that's cool easter egg i really
love that a lot it's why eric voss
rocks rock star similar to wanda's
confused greeting when she first meets
white vision in the comics but this mac
os vision doesn't play nice
oh that bone crunch sound effect luckily
vision knocks them into a winnebago and
boom
looking for a white vision walking right
out of those flames like the terminator
t-100
a true killing machine now i love the
camera motion following wanda's glide up
and then
back through the window glass hey monica
always appreciate it
your contact shots i've seen geography
like we always know where in west view
we
are so you don't know where for a reason
the action's very easy to track i love
it now
fietro traps monica in his man cave
using a super speed to tap her off her
feet
i hope you really explain all this
i love that ping an indicator that
monica herself is pretty sturdy and even
though fietro is i guess
not fox x-men quicksilver this man cave
is super momentum
yes things we saw with quicksilver these
future past
so you just said some people
vision does have the edge by phase
shifting through white vision's blows
but notice how over the course of the
battle white vision learns from this
so that later in the library he catches
vision off guard
by the same kind of patient he's
learning i love the shot where white
vision rises from the crack pavement
trying to drag
vision down because white vision is
essentially a zombie corpse
from the grave dragon vision and angelic
form conceived in this afterlife
back down to hell now paul benton is wow
this was a big secret cameo that he
teased and they're gonna be so
disappointed when they find out
you son of a [ __ ] i don't mind this i
think bethany's great in both roles
but his trolling did kind of contribute
to a perfect storm of fan expectation
chaos something that we go into in
inside marvel go check that out
now it was much easier to forgive the
paul bettany troll
then something else in this episode but
damn
i don't know what paul penny was
thinking yeah i was like you gotta know
by now that people are gonna lose their
minds over them it's the first time he's
like leading and starring
in a marvel property and i'm like oh i
guess you just haven't paid attention
the last 10 years how these things go
down huh
we all get hazed in some way shape or
form hayward screen shows the
comparative vibranium decay of both
visions notice vision represented in
gold has a higher concentration than
white vision
that's because white vision's vibranium
is older more decayed than his
hex counterpart whose vibranium was
manifested like weeks ago
jimmy wu snatches the mic in sight of
this sword agent who i just assume just
hates hayward
he picks the lock with flourish another
nod too he's close-up magic classes
now one of my greatest pleasures
throughout these breakdowns of one
division is pointing out just random
background extras in west view doing
goofy npc [ __ ] behind wanda is
this dapper dan frozen with his foot on
the hydrant it's not an easter egg i
just love this weirdo he
never
[Music]
truck that wasn't at all related to
anything
don't shoot i'm just a messenger now he
said the same thing back in episode two
don't shoot i'm just a messenger i'm
starting to think that dennis might just
be jimmy woo's missing witness
if you look closely in episode five we
never id'd on their id wall but we never
got a close look at what was written on
that file the missing witness is
definitely not
theatre slash route okay we'll get to
why later he's just seen this way to
keep me home
who would cooperate with the feds to
turn in his past criminal associates
and then him saying don't shoot him just
a messenger is something you could
imagine
someone like that that's a good point
there's a big gun in his face
that's a great point yeah i think
sometimes you just say things
and when you're writing stuff and you're
like adds a detail we don't even it's
fbi [ __ ]
if there's like some deleted scene or if
we do find out later i i think that's a
really well made argument for why
agatha confirms that her spell book is
indeed the dark hold
marvel's book of the damned this is
potentially the biggest confirmation of
this episode see in the comics the dark
hold was a collection of spells written
by
and i think i got the right
pronunciation here shitan
the demon
she has no coven no need for incantation
forge likely refers to her forgery by
the mind stone because it was that
infinity stone implication
that made wanda the scarlet witch with
nexus level powers unique among
the witches but ironically agaves says
this in front of a billboard for
squeaky shine using the power of mother
earth
honda's untaught magic is a natural
phenomenon whereas
agatha according to her latin bullying
moore's monstro naturai
she's a freak of nature and aberration
in nature she cheated via
supernatural means and notice the book
once again
that's so funny because when she was in
front of that billboard i kept looking
at it and i was like
is there something meaningful is there
some type of
reference that could be everybody just
couldn't
the book once again glows a fiery orange
color
the same color of magic that seemed to
protect agatha from the blue spells
and allowed her purple magic to take
over and drain the rest of the coven
presumably that magic came from the dark
hold and whatever demonic entity or
entities are contained within
now the dark gold is the source of all
supernatural horrors in the marvel world
like expect this book to come back in
multiverse of madness and played
many believe it belongs among the other
spell books in this
library this looks way older like
there's no way librarian wong would let
it get into this shape i'm thinking this
book actually
predates that entire library it's far
more dangerous than anything in there
but inside this book these ancient runes
and geometric illustrations like notice
that hexagon framing the scarlet witch
there
to link this magic of agatha in her
coven to the marvel sorcerers
she even references doctor strange here
your power exceeds that of the sword
it's your destiny to destroy the world
and by destroying the world i think we
can presume she means
breaking apart the universe into a
multiverse of alternate worlds
that might be so experienced
could be referring to now by the way
this is a very different dark hole than
the one in agents of shield or in
runaways
further telling us that those titles
might not be ensued
you know what i gotta say too i think
it's so cool
how this show has us so hyped up for dr
strange multiverse and madness and yet
there was never a direct
tease or like a like a post-credit scene
or doctor strange appearing
nothing that's overtly like it's a
doctor strange setup yeah yeah
and i love that you know because
normally that's what marvel has to do to
get us
really excited for the next installment
but all they have to do is tell us
beforehand
that no what happens in wana vision will
be really important to doctor strange
they just had to tell us that and now
we're all
it's like doctor strange welcome course
management trending like really
soon after this episode aired so like
yeah i love that i absolutely love that
and did you guys see gabriel luna's uh
tweet oh i knew i shouldn't have left
that under my pillow or something like
that
never why i was hoping you could come
back man
with the multiverse maybe one day all
this [ __ ] can be mcu cannon
except for quicksilver real name is
sarah proctor sarah proctor was the
daughter of the proctor family a family
accused of witchcraft during the salem
witch trials her father
john proctor was hanged now sarah's
husband is harold proctor aka jones
so presumably this is the name she
married into unless
harold took her name like i could see
him doing that yeah
progress to bella mustache seemed to
also be a witch in west view at least so
far
but with agatha's survival this nosy
neighbor could identify
another witch with salem roots to try to
mint her to take under her wing how does
that which is an
ongoing thing in the mcu seven months
later in spider-man car from home with
mr dell's superstition
leaving because of witches welcome to
the new dark ages
so monica realizes that theatre is
actually ralph
the ralph lauren looking for the whole
pie husband agave can't shut up about
his name is ralph
boner look i'll have more thoughts on
why this whole evan peters casting
misdirect happened in the first place
there's actually probably a very good
reason for it we're gonna talk about an
inside marble but for his part evan
peters had this to say about his cameo
dude i'm such a huge fan of the marvel
universe it was so cool
to come over there and hang out with all
those guys as if this
might not be an ongoing thing going
forward now the name boner could be a
nod to agatha's oft mentioned
intimacy issues with ralph or more
likely not to growing pains mike
siever's buddy richard steboon
aka boner yeah that was his nickname and
miss 80 sitcom now growing pains was a
reference point on the episode evan
peter's first
director matt shackman got his showbiz
start as a child actor
on just the ten of us which was a
growing pain spin-off so the guy's got
boners on the brain
i'm really connected and the charges go
way up in the month of october
maybe because that's when the hex
started
what a fun detail she looks good
gardening
using a lot of hose water i don't know
they might still be the one degree of
bloom after all
so you mean to tell me during wanda's ex
they still got electrical build charges
never underestimate the capitalist
system my friend they
always find a way to get that building
one is like let the dwp
come through we can't we can't have it
let's see world hindering the economy
all right let's
keep things good i don't know they might
still be the wonderful ever bloom after
all especially that if it's not dead
she's going to be growing stuff in that
town can't wait to revisit catherine
hunt now she also gets this from the
name on his head shot
meaning ralph is an aspiring actor i
actually assume they used one of evan
peters real early
fact that water bills overdue an
aspiring actor living in west view new
jersey in that house
uh-uh the guy's broke ralph is not jimmy
wu's missing witness folks this isn't
like a casting assignment that's not
what they do for people
he's just an actor and people in federal
witness protection are forbidden from
any attention-grabbing behavior like
going anywhere you might appear on the
news
or attempting to break an acting career
that plus his water bill goes back
several months and jimmy
said his witness moved there recently
and jimmy saw pietro on screen and
didn't say anything so stop asking me if
ralph is the federal witness yeah
but he's not but then billy yeah yeah
you saw it
before she actually does that in the
following scene that means billy can
see the future like raven one that
pleads her case
you're fine i've kept you
safe you feel at peace
does this sound like the kind of
rationale other mcu villains use like
loki's saying is this not wanda's a
villain he's expecting the universe to
be grateful what is a villain all mean
well
but as agatha correctly points out
heroes don't torture people
no who does villains she's going to be a
villain doesn't feel like me merciful by
opening the hex
i gotta say if you guys haven't heard
jeremy john's review
on the last episode he pointed out
something really great hayward
is not really a villain that hayward
yeah he's got like a dick attitude
but juan is really the villain of this
whole season and hayward is just trying
to you know
save the people of west view yes he's
building a sentient weapon and all that
but he's not really doing anything
that's villainous other than his
attitude and the fact that we root for
wanda yeah and we know her
intimately and everything about her
struggle like they throw in the moment
where he tries to shoot one of the kids
but that's about as far as it went and
it was it was put in the last
episode but prior to that it's really
been wanda who's the bad guy
and i love that i'm still in one decide
someone like hayward team hayward man
where's my hayward t-shirt from new
rockstar i'm just saying it's a
fascinating perspective opening the hex
walls which with this red color
does kind of evoke the parting of the
red sea by moses
which would let the hebrew slaves flee
to freedom but also let's end the cruel
pharaoh in this case
as the town glitches the movie theater
marquee toggles between ones we've
discussed big red and kidnapped the way
these people are kidnapped in a big red
hex also visionate big red gum
oz the green powerful and this modern
one tan hauser gate which is an odd to
the tears of brain monologue in blade
runner this episode also deals with the
philosophy of ai and metaphysics
like you can see a yellow poster for
this movie the post-credits scene looks
like a rom-com maybe a kids movie
but the theater name is the coronet
theater cornet is a small
crown reflecting the scarlet witch crown
the center of lotus identity and
agatha's envy
also during this glitching you can
briefly see a billboard flipping to an
ad for hydra
soak the soap commercial from episode
three just like how we saw it
we saw his last episode and with the hex
now open vision billy and tommy begin to
disintegrate and their particles are
these tetracy jigsaw they're producing
the walls of one's house as she
constructed it last episode
amazing house of m cover art that i've
referenced like a million times and the
family lines up like the incredibles
in the library is this banner reading
the library is a place to be
with beehive hexagons which i only bring
up because clearly agent franklin's
beekeeper form had to mean something
another loose end that we will address
an inside marvel
or it could be related to doctor who and
how the bees are all the bees
missing the bees are missing i forgot
what the bees actually meant in that
episode we watched but yeah and then
vision cleverly tricks white vision with
a logical paradox i request elaboration
i'm gonna use the [ __ ] out of that so
vision brings up these shits of species
from greek philosophy
how much can you replace the pieces of
something until its identity has now
changed with white vision stuck in a
paradox
both are the true ship and neither are
the true ship this is kind of the way
they try to defeat robot santa with a
logical paradox of pedrama
consider this you are programmed to
destroy the naughty
but many of those you destroy are in
fact nice
i submit to you that you are naughty and
that logically you must destroy yourself
unfortunately for white vision his head
wasn't built with paradox absorbing
crumble zones
so vision offers a solution to the
paradox perhaps
the rot is the memories the wear and
tear of the voyages
the wood touched by theseus himself so
vision is saying
memory determines identity the soul
that's a big reason why it's so
meaningful lately
as an extension of her soul he echoes
this same concept
i have been a voice with no body a body
but not human and now
a memory made real vision restores the
memories from the data inside white
vision showing us lots of mcu flashbacks
first
panels showing characters in the moments
from age of ultron iron man hulk the
hulkbuster armor paul and joannasburg
marvel studios correct opening logos his
birth and avengers tower then shuri
scanning his head infinity war
the moment he grabbed which is kind of
what this moment with white vision is
paralleling the gold versus the blue
color tones
gold representing the jarvis voiced
vision blue representing a soulless a.i
then when he wielded mjolnir and fought
centuries in that cecovian church
wanda fighting him to save hawkeye in
civil war his
two deaths at the hands of wanda and
then thanos and wakandan and city
a shot of him firing that beam that hit
roadie in the civil war airport battle
you can actually see giant scott behind
him there
wanda flirting with him in avengers
compound vision helping her up after
that airport battle wanda cupping his
face in scotland an infinity war then
wanda trying to heal for displaced wound
right after that and then thanos getting
that mind stone turning him into the
corpse
editors had a blast with these memories
restored white vision declares himself
vision
and blast the high ambition by
peace maybe the apple store to
[ __ ] an ipod i don't know we're gonna
talk more about white vision's future
in tomorrow's q a wanda teasingly
vanishes in front of agatha
signaling to us that she has been
picking up some of agatha's moves and
has another learned tactic upper sleeve
the boys
handle the military love that line with
tommy stealing a hat the way quicksilver
stole a hat as a speedster in the x-men
films
dammit children so it looks like that
first shot would have gone between them
hayward poorly shoots at children but
monica heroically jumps in front to take
the bullets
she doesn't know these kids have
superpowers like she does so that's nice
of her now this time her eyes glows
yellow this time her eyes kind of glow a
different color reflecting whatever
radiation she's connected
perhaps here maybe it's the gunfire or
the metal of the bullets but either way
the bullets refract through her and then
slow and then drop out the other side
just another example of monica's
abilities as spectrum or photon whatever
name they're gonna go with absorbing
all forms of energy and sort of
redirecting it or reapplying it but
interestingly notice her eyes follow a
bullet as it whizzes past her
a sign that she also must be capable of
moving as super super i've never
thought of that then i love it darcy
rams hayward
in that funnel cake truck which remember
that warped from an armored truck in
episode six
it actually works back to that later and
remember warped materials retain their
composition explaining why
it's still a funnel truck
in this case agatha's nightmare is the
painful memory of her witch trial
seeing her coven resurrect might have
been why she was so fearful of wanda
being able to raise the dead but then
the coven turns on
harbinger of chaos with her red crown
forming her head linking it to the blue
crown that formed on evanor's head but
wanda ends up breaking out of this using
agatha's envy for the chaos magic
against her feeding her more of it and
more of it while luring her into a trap
of
runes that disable her magic just like
the ones agatha used to trap wanda
how did she learn rude so fast she tries
to use her magic but nothing happens
just like thanos and endgame
inevitable
so wanda absorbs agatha's magic and
becomes the full scarlet witch
amazing costume that looks great
right one of the runes down in the
basement maybe hinting at a future house
of m event in multiverse madness
m shape in her crown and this other
interesting runic shape on her belt
buckle i'm wondering if both of these
could be some sort of protective runes
that would protect wanda the scarlet
witch wherever she goes
very cool design i gotta say though how
did she learn the runes so fast did she
really not know was it be embracing the
scarlet witch
that just allowed her to like have these
exponential powers and me
because because in the timeline of when
this occurred
we have a week apart when watching it
from the timeline it's been like
hours an hour you know it hasn't been
that
long yeah is this fixed up immediately
after the events of the of episode eight
it kind of feels like a bit of a nitpick
maybe yeah it was one of those things
where i think they did a really nice job
actually of like visually showing
like how she works it into the fight but
at the same time i'm like yeah how would
she have known
she just memorized exactly those runes
and hoped for the best does she actually
know what they mean or is it one of
those things where it's like
i'm going to intend for something and
it's going to carry me
out because she seems to be doing a lot
unintentionally and then the ear
seems obviously intentional
i mean don't get me wrong still a badass
moment hell yeah
some are comparing wanda's wardrobe to
magneto michael fassbender's look but
i really love how it incorporates the
color true she now possesses
the way agaves purple and blue dressed
that's good
i think that's true because like i i had
a
um i had a thumb like this looks like a
real mutant costume something out of the
x-men universe
but i couldn't quite pinpoint why and
then you see this side-by-side
and you you do feel a very big
similarity
absolutely i don't know if that's
intentional or not but
damn that is if you were to show if you
were to be like they're crossing over
and you show these images you're like oh
that looks like their father and
daughter right here well i wouldn't put
it past marvel to be refining the way in
which they parson out these hints and
details and so yeah it could be
something more on the subconscious level
for right now that could be aliens
yeah and then they bring in michael
fossbender and just call him harry p
ness yes yeah definitely and then bring
in mcavoy and he could be mike hunt
yeah i really love how it incorporates
the colors of all the magic she now
possesses
the way agaves purple and blue dress did
here wanda's red and act this purple mix
to form this dark dark scarlet and then
you can see little stripes of blue on
the legs
she's got this great color of the mind
stone of agave
and of the other members of that coven
and wanda now if you listen has a bit
more of a second accent comeback
decides to imprison agava as a nosy
neighbor agnes
in west view i'm sorry no you're not
you're cruel they're cruel you have no
idea what you've unleashed
indeed a dark move by wanda to trap
agatha in this dollhouse root she's done
dark moves already that turns into agnes
notice she retains the brooch no matter
what that stays with her
but now it's kind of a way wanda can
identify her almost like
a scarlet letter and then the two parts
i'll be seeing your agnes
that's just for your first time if i see
you first
sounds like a veiled threat agatha may
come back to haunt wanda before
wanda expects it and then wanda
envisioned tuck in the boys saying
family is forever and wanda
interestingly says this
boys thanks for choosing me to be your
mom
huh another sign that these boys might
have come from a source
outside yeah here we go
[Music]
watching their world collapse around
them but then juanta says this
beautiful monologue you vision
are the piece of the mind stone that
lives in me
you are a body of wire
blood i love his eyes here
you are my sadness and my hope
and like we dude vision cries a single
tear matching that panel in avengers 58
and they promise to find each other
again
maybe wanda's future in the multiverse
could result in a vision from an
alternate reality merging with white
vision similar to the insanity that
restores vision in the comics but right
now we're getting ahead of ourselves
this is about letting go
not figuring out when we're gonna find
each other again and as we cut from
wanda's hex to reality you may notice
her right hand starts being higher
and then suddenly her left hand is
higher on the other side of the cut but
i don't think that's a mistake cause a
real detail here emotional trigger
warning her wedding band and her
engagement ring are
also now missing from her left hand so
the last thing
fading hex did was lift the rings off
her finger
essentially reversing them
you know the production team she really
should get more credit for their
attention to detail on this
supervisors oh that is so heartbreaking
uh so many stories and little like more
than clues and easter eggs there's often
enhancement of story within the
production design of these marvel
properties well what a bookend too
you know wanda finds herself back in the
empty lot as if nothing has happened
dorothy waking up from the dream nothing
is happening
nothing is cool when your world is gone
you realize it was all a bad dream
but the people of westby will never
forget way to ruin it for all mutants
wound up and these
are the mutants but monica at least
wishes her well
bye wanda
[Applause]
good luck good luck does take wanda back
to that simple probability hex that she
could cast as a kid
back when bringing herself good luck was
as magical as it got for her
but my oh my how this witch has grown
post credit scene number one
this girl is an associate of nick fury
an old friend of maria and monica rambo
from the days of captain marvel
setting up monica to join fury on that
scroll space station that we see him on
and apart from home post credits yes
which is again seven months after this
by the way i'm thinking this is not
taylor's daughter because monica
probably would have recognized her and
be like hey buddy nice eyes
transformation directly in the lens
flare of that projector light
kind of a weird shot setup right i'm
thinking maybe it's another visual
setting up monica's future
as photon or spectrum which both names
come from the fact that she has an
electromagnetic physiology but the final
final
scene picks up airway mountain lake
we got a couple options for where this
could be this could be just her home
country of sokovia some are saying it
could be alkali lake
the location of the weather next slab
that created wolverine or it could be
wounded mountain the location of the
citadel of the high evolutionary
where magda gave birth to wanda and
pietro in the comics
showed up in episode two remember bova
is the bovine nursemaid created by the
high evolutionary
what should just be like colorado yes
it's just the place you went just to
hide yeah that's the place she saw on a
postcard when she was young and she just
went there if this is wundergore that
tea
wanda bruise could be that winter ever
bloom urbai theorized agave was brewing
for her in episode seven there's
something weird going on here
wanda freaking bare hands the metal
handle of a tea kettle that was just
boiling
i guess the girl likes it hot now what's
going on here wanda is using astral
projection
into her scarlet witch form to examine
the darkhold kinda like the way doctor
strange used astral projection to study
sorcery while he was sleeping
but the fact that wanda is doing it
while awake is troubling because
how is she splitting her consciousness
like this everyone else does it when
they're either incapacitated
like that seems to be pulling alternate
versions of herself already from
alternate realities to be able to do
this but listen to the music here
this is michael g aquino's doctor
streams he's the number one comment
in our reaction
and chiquino composed the opening marvel
studios title card theme that this
version of it actually first appeared in
the doctor strange movie in
years that's the most doctor strange has
been here with us in one division
the whole time but in the final seconds
from the dark hold
wanda hears the voices of billy and
tommy calling for help
as wanda's eyes widen with recognition
we flash
to red what's going on here well how do
we get here
remember the camera swooped in from an
insane
distance and without cutting it glides
all the way into the back interiors
notice that yeah
very evil dead sam raimi it's like we
are a disembodied spirit a fellow astral
projection
watching wanda maybe doctor strange the
sorcerer supreme whose powers wanda has
apparently surpassed
and the avengers she will probably be a
villain too in multi-person madness
i think is recreating what we saw in the
dark
pages the wavy wavy-haired sorceress
creating these circle hexes
doing what channeling her nexus powers
to tap into the multiverse
to find an ultimate reality like the one
she created however she could go on to
be with vision and her sons but the
problems
it makes us wonder what darker threat
this scarlet witch
unleashed to use the word of agatha's
warning look there's all kinds of
demonic forces out there
we're gonna meet at least one of them in
multiverse of madness i win the other
video while i'm still on that crazy
mephisto train obviously not for the
nine episodes of one division he was a
total no show
hundreds of you have been very kind to
remind me
now that marvel has said i'm sorry
there's always a future marvel title
loki multiverse of madness
just saying that those demon spawn are
still in the mix the devil is still in
the details
honestly i don't really care about that
right now i'm just in full appreciation
for this series
it's creepy funny heartbreaking
mysterious nonsense
and being able to theorize about it week
to week with you all
so thank you so much for sticking with
me you know that new rock stars is
always aimed for more than just like
theory accuracy like if you were with us
before wandavision you know that all too
well
and if you found us through one division
welcome the madness is just beginning
another reminder to check out our
unusual couples shirt which is still
available but selling out fast because a
new latest
obsession collectible will be announced
soon get it at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for
everything marvel thanks for watching
boners
yeah you know like i think um i think
one division
was a spectacular series it was a real
beautiful moment for all of us and
like i said at the beginning of this
video you know that's part of the fun is
theorizing and i've never seen it before
to the point where people seem legit
like mad
at people who do easter eggs and
theories for getting
pumped up and then rubbing it in
people's faces
for when they're wrong i'm like whoa you
guys are getting out of
hand here this is supposed to be fun
this is part of the joy of jumping into
these things and probing at them and
seeing
it's like whether you found it or not
what they just focus on the story itself
they just focus on giving us proper
conclusions to the emotional beats they
set up
what the hell they didn't just focus on
minutia
i think it's one thing to criticize the
episode or the series based off of what
was actually given to us versus
what you were expecting to see or what
you're now hoping might happen
yeah because the final episode is
definitely not my favorite episode of
the season i loved it
in so many ways um there were criticisms
i obviously
had i don't think it's the strongest one
but as a as a whole package of a series
it's like 9.98 out of 10 for me you know
like it's pretty
high up there so yeah like i think it's
just been a great experience
and the fact that this was marvel like
mcu's first real show to have this
week-to-week theorizing easter egg
hunting like i've never been involved in
an experience like that
with a series where you're like this
will affect the future of the mcu
and we're all trying to theorize
together and it's just been a blast and
that's part of the fun and
it's part of what happens with fandom so
i think this has just been a great
experience
and we just gotta appreciate the hard
work that marvel's put into it
absolutely this is
the highest production tv show i've ever
seen probably not that those lines
really mean that much anymore but yeah
this was something that was really
impressive and it was a step outside the
box for them and had a lot of stuff we
love about step outside the box i put us
in a box oh
hexagon box as much as it's fun to get
wrapped up in these theories what they
paid off was the right stuff and the
only thing i could
not really argue you out of being upset
about is the whole boner thing
but even that got a little better
looking at what eric said here
so kind of i mean i i'm still like
what were you thinking marvel especially
knowing it's a week-to-week show they
would know
that most people would be excited at the
idea of quicksilver being in it like yes
i get it for storytelling purposes like
all right fine whatever
not the point but at the same time even
though the reveal of
who he really is who ralph really is the
amount of emphasis i'm putting up and
peter's in here
they kept him hidden for a reason and
the way
they they hid him from onset photos and
stuff they really kept it private like
they would put like
things over his head while transporting
to make sure people there's a reason
they hit him because they knew fans
would react this way
yeah so um i do think it is like a
kind of a messed up move you know
they they've learned a lot over time
about how to do things but i'm sure that
there's still a couple things they have
to figure out
yeah especially when they are expanding
the boundaries and getting a little more
wild and having a little more fun
with it you know i mean it's a thin line
between a joke and a troll
so i do think that this was uh this is
amazing
thank you very much for and all the
whole team and new rockstars for all the
hard work you guys put in
i mean love your heads videos can't wait
to see what you guys do falcon winter
soldier man
and don't worry mephisto will come oh
he's got
i believe i believe in memphis the new
shirts
that's the new rockstar shirt that's
coming up one day air boss used to be an
old man rocking his [ __ ] i swear
to god welcome next
eric they brought me fisto into the mcu
he just rolls over dies a brooch falls
[Laughter]
rest in peace eric all right guys well
leave your thoughts down below on the
show
subscribe hit that like button click the
notification bell subscribe to rockstars
you haven't done so already last but not
least
adelia chamberlain adelia i haven't
talked to you in a while that is
completely and entirely my
fault so behind on all my messages but i
know how much you were looking forward
to this series
and i hope that it has been a great
sense of escapism for you
week to week i just want you to know
that i'm so behind i'm replying to you
but you haven't left my thoughts
and every day i feel a little bit of a
guilt pressure be like crap
let's get back you're leaving the delia
out to languish
but it's okay adelia because uh we love
you
and uh we're gonna create our own little
hex reality where this doesn't have to
happen anymore you just wait you don't
have to wait for messages we can just
communicate freely you'd
bomb and i'm about to light that fuse
and you're gonna
blow up and uh and i'll be thrown in
jail for murdering you
know if you light off the adelia bomb in
a safe place
with not a lot of stuff around you could
probably get away with it and call it an
exhibition